I guess chapter 23 station was only the
first stop on my journey but the car one
went on Calvin so before parting ways we
drunk to celebrate that I can't get the
what kid didn't drown my fear of
traveling on to Polly said okay but I
was about to find myself with an
unexpected and notorious I can't get get
I love baron I'll see this oh I like
this man hello hello Sarah a chair seein
all right boys what's three into our
friend thank you who goes right through
monsters and anomalies alike door that
thank you thank you oh and I'll take
that right thank you okay hell if not
for you our tomb would have been
shredded like cabbage you deserve a
mallet and sure she's some extra ammo
here take oh oh yes to you take that is
I'm doing uh what is that water drink
cup looks like empty
okay okay hell oh thank you i'm just
getting up you really muted that chip
seal that shroom vodka nice em down here
ma'am okay we've got to check that don't
love me singers and what job do your
help I like how restaurants they're
allowed guns no table at something
Americans missing you know I will get
there get there ah the latke kicks
everyone's ass huh okay I thought the
market school again I'll lose in our can
always enough
find a way a station ok let me play such
a nice cup to take that are too you know
they will leave their money damn just
gonna take it you know like not not here
to waste up ok I'll take this I got my
Roderick let me out of the station and
what the hell do you care if I live or
die I don't care [ __ ] but I got my
orders ok get lost yes sir
uh-huh he's gonna spaced out this man
hello
guess I'm on this way but let me this
job did you really come here on hand car
I bet I did meth kids filters not okay
max Evans all right hey looks really she
looks like we know where to go I'll get
a spanking uh hello sir yeah are you uh
I guess to be in the army there's Amon
at the blocks park went out for you he's
kind of big and scary and she doesn't
smell the beam erases all right oh god
you there Palumbo yeah sure thanks let's
go oh yeah what I never found that Jesus
kind of crouched
ok
Jesus
Oh God keep hitting my head but I missed
a bunch of good stuff but it's all right
hey little one is following boys in the
dark that's kind of not good for our
soldier but all right you know if the
game is scripted that way I guess that's
the way to go huh now Jim come here
you're out till right sit down yes yes I
am let me just see if there's any money
here keV is none i guess it could sit
down how do i oh okay hello everybody
calls me Borbon listen I need to get to
dry station for some business but this
rat hole is on lockdown I however know a
back way a so-called cursor passage the
locals are afraid to you okay but I hear
the [ __ ] in the tunnels doesn't work on
you so you help me get to dry i'll give
you my retail of course deal deal good
he is an advance payment in case you
need to gear up first yes are you ready
see Sir sitting in this crap all is
useless that's like my dear to
instructor just kidding I wouldn't do
that support for any metal money okay
you don't know like archery you know
safe distance and you can still [ __ ]
damage you know um salsa yeah ok let's
go sir let's go alright a little faster
um I guess there's no rush I get it I
get it
booski Bravo Peppa dusky raspa Pritchett
eerie Ranma Bridget eerie dig no doctors
robbery Potter ski ok he has rasca yeah
ik kuri let's go ma'am anything in here
hidden no no I just like money I'm sorry
as i entered the abundant tunnel with
bourbon I wondered if I'd be wrong to
trust Anna but the station gates were
still sealed and there was no telling
when I would have another chance to live
free yes yes great we brought bread now
keep your eyes peeled the hand car ride
is over lots of tough guys died in these
tunnels but if we watch each other's
backs we'll get there
okay I love the nature [ __ ] they rarely
attack groups of people but if you're
alone watch your ass okay am I gonna be
alone yes Oh sir Sir um taking us that's
a gun nothing else here oh Jesus Sarah
you're gonna wait up for me or what like
a native my strange sounds either the
ground is making that noise or the wing
I also heard tales of singing pipes they
say is you listen long enough you can
hear the voices of the Dead what Oh be
extra quiet here there should be a
roadblock in second tunnel we don't want
to draw their attention well have a
shotgun so that's not gonna work too
well oh oh look little squirrels okay it
seems I'm stuck okay any money here I
like money yeah I also like magazines um
but I understand it's hard to come by um
okay let's go shit's caravanners they're
all dead I know their money find it and
so posted that they've wiped them out ah
ah now keep your eyes peeled they won't
let us pass freely heck is this is that
a lot of system ancient but quite
efficient if you want to arrive
unexpected try not to disturb the cans
okay um not a can guy but I get what
we're doing here watch your step any
crunch or crackle give you away all
right Jason to ask
okay three-point an excellent way to get
rid of the blind and Daredevils okay i
heerd dangerous musica okay trip wires
how the heck am I supposed to okay okay
um ma'am so does it disarmed can't tell
okay okay quiet we have guests a ship I
did not corner and watch out and
Goldberg round works
yeah portrait Elia Groot papa Samia no
spotless liya na yacon kanya Cat Cat Cat
ok guys where we love now I guess I'll
see anything but
uh sir oh ok oh that hurt reloading man
it's a sukkah killed one of us oh so
it's coming oh [ __ ] ok ok oh [ __ ] she
probably reload yeah probably not down
to huh you know like it really did you
hot with these gun things where's that
sir right there Oh reload reload ok is
there like a med kit or let me just
figure out how to use them might get
that what's key oh it's cute ok dead ok
that's great good killed on a man jumper
losing big balls that's way to kill a
man with my comrade anyone now no
I guess no one knows that's fine walk
just made a lot of noise
[ __ ] get a shot off like crazy yeah yeah
kick it out drugs thank God me yeah that
your ex
san e pin but then again I don't have
the best eyes okay okay we're doing this
or doing this we gotta got like a
million amo jesus
let's see what Elly is
okay it looks like I'm just gonna have
to go shotty and I like how does my help
work I don't know
in the jungle we've got visitors
[ __ ] that guys almost dead okay okay
calm down guys [ __ ] okay okay come back
go back I get any ammo for this No
oh my god okay there's so many guys here
actually shet she dead okay okay now
he's not dead what the [ __ ]
okay I guess I'm just like ever so
slowly killing all them ok I got that
guy oh now this guy shows up like after
I kill everybody ok that's fine I guess
no no no i mean like everyone has their
preferences like it can't really be mad
you know like
share just saw so much stuff to [ __ ] is
this
no thanks no thanks get my shotty back
okay okay okay okay it's good i like
your loot i like your loot thank you
thank you okay
what's the plant okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] died all right let's try
this again
chef where's the other guy this guy like
a ball is it a chicken shed what's a
[ __ ] I'm like out here clearing rooms
and this guy is just like running around
ok so i know you got loot there you go
there you go down as my texts are you
just happy to see me okay okay okay
we're at the bridge it's fine you're
just a nasty place so here's the plan
I'll keep you covered and you watch my
back if we work together we make it but
don't play hero boy I'm in no mood to
get killed today oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] someone unloaded a lot of [ __ ] here
what is that like beeping noise
what the [ __ ] is that oh [ __ ]
ok sir all right it's gonna [ __ ] up some
fish ok you know where we got sir I
don't know if I like this mechanic it
just makes it harder yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ]
okay where are the other ones ah [ __ ]
you [ __ ] oh yeah you like that oh yeah
get from La Liga for daddy
oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
get the taste sec it tastes
oh there yes sir all right
acadian [ __ ] and instead of kiss how
convenient spot seems to me we're
beating you again Maggie you can't what
what's gone on here ok ok sir
d
[ __ ] okay okay [ __ ] made it the [ __ ]
is that very [ __ ] on okay I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on here I
see this guy's a little [ __ ] that's
what I say
Marcus station was just a little further
but bourbon warned me that our paths
went through the lost catacombs suka as
if masala scanners were not enough now
we're stacking up to search the bodies
I'll try to get down absence out of you
thanks dear it's like the first thing
you've done in like ten years it's
[ __ ] that apuleius Top Chef out the
hell okay and I gay yes I get this give
it a wet change something with the fun
again
come on
something is very wrong with this place
remember our agreement I'm counting on
another offer an ak-47 come on nice
little grill I promise you dear I will
come back and lubricant you also get
your new pain oh the great door I hear
you are calling me it's can't wait what
Oh search the bodies Olivia
uh yes so you gotta go through the gate
I see now I say now I just completely
went into the patient okay okay no no
foul you know over there come on Joe
he's got it wrong
remember I 13
counting on you come on nice little
grill I promise you dear I will come
back in lubricate you also get your new
babe oh the great door I hear you are
calling me
alright
I
done
what
tripping balls
wait ah okie the flashlight on uh-oh so
Nolan bodies I'll try to get down here
pickups come on open
I'm Jill I got
come on nice little grill I promise you
dear I will come back and lubricate you
also get your new paint oh the great
door I hear you are calling me
God's got
Brown
oh hey I survived something out what the
hell was that a joke did you hear those
songs huh I wouldn't wish it on and I
mean the hell song was that Allah Allah
Allah very there's press upon bunch but
you know you're tougher than you look
let's go move we're almost demonic it
would be a pity to get eaten when we're
so close by something so good here [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] trap
[ __ ] where my comrade go this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know I'm saying okay let's
go say let's go sighs just the market
and here is the market stay calm uncle
bourbon will get us in okay
hey people open up don't let your
two-legged brother and I a foolish death
are you deaf in there you're going to be
chess as they can [ __ ] the hell
did you drive with your damn das Alice's
Jimmy one start the trolley will set the
racers a girl hang on pleats on the
outside ok ok I'm a nice people wouldn't
get elected
current pace
Oh
oh my [ __ ] too so tight right now
oh [ __ ]
okay we good okay yo show yourselves do
as he says these guys have no sense of
humor are my eyes playing tricks bourbon
old friend is that you and I had given
up hope of ever seeing you alive again
Simon look who the snout scare that god
damn it we stepped in this [ __ ] now hey
Miguel vids for the coincidence I was
just coming to visit you you hear that
boys set out the good dishes Urban's
come to visit now don't go running hard
we've got a little job to finish then
we'll get back to you remember where you
should wait for me I do I do you sure I
can help you remember you get me right
absolutely there's a bigger sky
I'd never seen a market like this you
could buy almost anything but move on
owed money to the Hansa centuries and
was anxious to leave holster your
weapons it was were you I mean to the
light so we slowly so the damn poor bull
hey guys we'd better search these two
yeah yeah very funny I cold so you all
drunk what are you getting this time
around who's the boy look here boss I'm
sure we can work this out sure let's go
in jet Alou and you keep an eye on this
one huh okay like a telescope no
okay don't still I'm talking deal
and
what's going on
okay these two may pass welcome to the
American a guy let's move our asses
would you like to enjoy that happen tle
mellitus castanets guys hey what's your
go you're in deep [ __ ] man no way I can
lay back to the railcar guys go around
well Moscow mark of a move it boy no of
solutions what's the occasion tonight
sighs
okay get that wasn't you
mama give me
just tell me
very good
everything you need when traveling make
sure you can count to five make sure you
can come to 52 B must always handy never
come would draw your junk away that's
for babies stop myself this stuff is
five times better than your toy guns
stars
ours are mesmo
one law your junk away that's for babies
or your junk away that's my babies all
the gate
p yes
this stuff is five times better than
your toy gun whatever
med gets this stuff is five times better
than your toy god this stuff is five
times better than your toy gone whatever
it is oh let's exchange
how is this okay
and I said what's up
and yes
all its exchange you won't find better
read in whole metro
you're welcome family oh it's exchange
you will find better rate in whole mess
room I'm oh shut up
whatever now
the conversation I left him like a gale
as usual okay didn't want to destroy the
crime well I made an arrangement with a
guy here who's a greedy [ __ ] but you
can't do anything about that didn't you
take my spare filter we need to get up
to the surface great it must call it I
think you already know the wedding this
is nice for my son with me please
respond Borbon as if you don't know go
[ __ ] and get out I've already paid Mike
you didn't pay me but if you don't want
to go through [ __ ] a pleasure doing
business with you all right all right
just kidding okay
ah get ready everyone the gate opening
ahead are you sure commander dick your
provisions governing damn I hate this so
much
you should be over me Larry
it looks clear oh oh